[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta a la reconstrucción de
la histórica catedral de notredam tras
el incendio de 2019 esta es la tercera
entrega ya pasaron cuatro años del
incendio que estuvo a punto de destruir
la catedral de notredam de París un
trauma para todos los franceses seguido
de una promesa la reconstrucción de la
catedral para 2024 ya que París será la
sede de los Juegos Olímpicos el año que
viene en la primera entrega visitamos la
obra hicimos un balance de los daños y
vimos Cómo se había asegurado el
edificio el año pasado nos encontramos
con todos los gremios que se movilizaron
a través del país para revivir anotoidam
en particular seguimos la restauración
de los grandes órganos de la Catedral
llevada a cabo en una pequeña empresa en
longle dog Pero antes de que los órganos
regresen a su lugar de origen se deben
terminar las obras y este año 2023 es
crucial está prevista que la aguja de la
Catedral vuelva a alzarse en el cielo
parisino a finales de este año en esta
nueva entrega de boleto de vuelta nos
encontramos con los artesanos encargados
de rehacer de forma idéntica la aguja
creada por el arquitecto viologic verán
que mientras uno se encargan de que la
catedral avance otros la examinan con
microscopio en busca de indicios sobre
la historia del monumento
en boleto de vuelta les prometimos
seguir paso a paso esta reconstrucción y
hacer un balance completo cada año Este
es el tercer episodio de nuestra serie
una obra titánica
Monumental
estamos en 300 kilómetros de París en el
patio de este hangar hay 80 toneladas de
vigas
son el taburete la base de la futura
aguja de notre dame
solo ha habido una obra como esta en mi
carrera soy carpintero hace 38 años es
la obra más hermosa es una obra
emblemática excepcional excepcional y
estoy muy agradecido de trabajar en una
obra como esta
es una obra maestra en realidad es una
obra complicada pero al mismo tiempo
estamos muy involucrados en ella
Entonces es una gran alegría
una alegría compartida por el resto de
los carpinteros encargados de verificar
que todo esté preparado
estamos haciendo una prueba de montaje
Para estar seguros de que todo va a
funcionar Y si hay detalles para
resolver los corregimos Para estar
seguros de que todo quede en su lugar
es muy demandante son piezas muy pesadas
de dimensiones muy grandes
y todas talladas Entonces es muy
complicado ensamblar
cuatro empresas se asociaron para
trabajar en la construcción de la nueva
aguja de notre
damelien lefer es el encargado de
supervisar el trabajo de sus compañeros
Aquí no hay margen para el error
[Música]
es una carrera pero lo tenemos bajo
control es una obra en la que los plazos
son muy importantes
cuando empecemos a montar el taburete en
el sitio de la obra aquí Seguiremos
tallando otros elementos de la aguja que
se instalarán más adelante la aguja
original que Data del siglo 19 fue
diseñada por el arquitecto Violet de
Duke Y aunque Hay bastante documentación
sobre ella reconstruirla ha sido un reto
permanente
También tenemos que rehacer de manera
idéntica esta estructura
trabajamos mucho con los archivos con la
investigación sobre los detalles con
todo eso
sí hay retos todos los días habrá retos
para instalarla porque las piezas son
excepcionalmente grandes y pesadas sobre
todo hay retos por los plazos
es una obra en la que hay que enfrentar
grandes retos casi todos los días
la obra es un reto pero también una
Revancha
15 de abril de 2019 las llamas devoran
la aguja de Violet leduc ante la mirada
de cientos de parisinos
[Aplausos]
durante un tiempo se sospechó que la
empresa
en ese momento estaba a cargo de la
renovación del techo de la Catedral
había sido la responsable del drama para
Julian legga eso fue un choque cuando
uno ve una joya de la arquitectura como
notre Dame en llamas delante de uno
recién habiendo empezado a trabajar en
lo que sin duda es uno de los mejores
proyectos de su carrera
es por supuesto un choque un cataclismo
es hecho que fue aún más devastador
porque recibimos todo tipo de
acusaciones injustas por parte de la
prensa de los medios pero ahora nuestro
nombre entre otros está en todas partes
porque estamos ayudando a reconstruir y
salvar la catedral pienso que esa es una
buena manera de pasar página la
investigación todavía no ha permitido
determinar las causas exactas del
incendio Pero giuliani y sus equipos
quedaron libres de sospecha y ahora
están entregados a la reco
ante las cámaras del mundo entero el
general enviado por Emanuel macron para
dirigir la restauración de notre dame
vino a comprobar el avance de la
reconstrucción de la aguja
para muchas personas el gran símbolo del
incendio fue cuando se desplomó la aguja
teléfono van la Fresh y cuando la vean
reaparecer al final de año en el cielo
de París sabrán que estamos cerca
Aunque hay muchos trabajos igual de
importantes que se están haciendo en el
interior y que las personas no ven
este es una etapa importante porque es
realmente un paso crítico de la
reconstrucción
y
es una etapa con una carga simbólica
considerable
[Música]
varias veces por semana esta embarcación
recorre el sena para entregar varias
toneladas de piedras que provienen de
canteras situadas en el departamento de
oís a tan solo una decena de kilómetros
de la capital
[Música]
esta piedra calcária tiene 45 millones
de años y fue seleccionada con sumo
cuidado porque sus características son
idénticas a la piedra original con la
que se construyó notre Dame algunas
serán usadas para reparar la estructura
de la catedral
otras para reemplazar las quimeras
gárgolas y otras estatuas afectadas por
el paso del tiempo aquí está trabajando
en un modelo para la cabeza y también
para la parte posterior de una quimera
porque todo esto estaba completamente
desgastado por el tiempo el hielo la
lluvia y el sol
está usando dibujos de la época
escogimos el modelo que más se parece al
que ella está haciendo
los bocetos de violette se han estudiado
hasta el más mínimo detalle
pero a pesar de la abundante
documentación dan ahí de 23 años que
trabaja en su primera obra debe
interpretar algunos trazos
hay que tratar de ser fiel no hay mucho
margen para la creación
pero trabajamos a partir de un dibujo y
siempre hay una diferencia con lo que
estamos haciendo por ejemplo las patas
no se parecen al dibujo porque
probablemente el boceto se hizo muy
rápido Entonces tenemos que
interpretarlo pero no lo estamos creando
de otra aplicación
estas esculturas no adornarán lo alto de
la Catedral servirán de modelo para una
nueva generación de estatuas esculpidas
en Piedras nuevas la quimera quedan ahí
está restaurando será exhibida en un
museo dedicado a la restauración le
estoy dando un ligero movimiento a la
cabeza para que se vea un poco más vivo
pero no sé si lo van a aceptar
[Música]
finalmente llegamos a notre Dame
en el interior es casi imposible
distinguir Los pilares o los muros de la
Catedral los andamios están por todas
partes Es un verdadero Laberinto en el
que es a veces difícil orientarse
[Música]
de repente un espacio abierto nos
permite vislumbrar el aspecto que tendrá
la catedral una vez finalice la
restauración
algunas partes de la Catedral han sido
restauradas y han alcanzado una blancura
desconocida los asistentes que visitarán
la catedral podrán entrar en poco más de
un año y descubrirán una catedral
magnificada por sus trabajos de limpieza
y restauración la verán tal como nunca
se ha visto por nuestros contemporáneos
poco a poco los atavíos de hierro van
desapareciendo y dan paso a los últimos
retoques detrás de cada lona hay un
artesano un restaurador o un obrero
trabajando en los detalles como detrás
de esta cortina de plástico que protege
a la gripagen del polvo de con paciencia
perfecciona los detalles en la
restauración de la pared del coro de
notre dame que se remonta al siglo xiv
decisión Esta es la pared del coro sur y
estoy poniendo pequeños puntos de color
en las zonas donde hay pequeñas lagunas
la línea negra se interrumpe en ciertas
partes Entonces la voy a continuar
así ligeramente para que se pueda ver el
conjunto y que el ojo no se detenga en
cosas que impidan la visualización del
conjunto
[Música]
que trabaja en los detalles en Bretaña
los científicos trabajan en los
laboratorios para reconstruir el pasado
Delfín
espalinóloga y analiza muestras tomadas
de un sarcófago descubierto en la
catedral bajo el cruce del transepto con
la nave central su objetivo es encontrar
granos de polen aquí agregamos distintos
ácidos uno después de otro para destruir
todo lo que no sea polen
es extremadamente resistente
el polen está hecho de es porolina
un material parecido al exoesqueleto de
los insectos
unos gramos de polvo recogidos durante
una campaña de excavación preventiva que
duró 9 semanas llevada a cabo en 2022
sobre una superficie de 123 metros
cuadrados para saber qué había debajo
del centro de la nave los arqueólogos se
encontraron estatuas esculturas y
fragmentos de la Catedral que datan del
siglo 13 pero también dos sarcófagos
enterrados a tan solo una decena de
centímetros del suelo que contenían
restos humanos
la presencia de esos huecos nos permitió
insertar una cámara endoscópica y
entonces pudimos ver en directo que
había adentro vimos claramente mechones
de pelo
quizás incluso restos de piel a nivel
del cráneo tejidos y algo que muy buenas
noticias sobre el estado de conservación
interno es que había toda una capa de
hojas a la altura de la cabeza
una mina de información para los
investigadores que trabajan por turnos
para obtener diversas muestras de esos
sarcófagos para nuestra palinóloga la
colecta se parece a una búsqueda del
tesoro entre lo infinitamente pequeño
Encontrar todos estos vegetales en
perfecto estado teniendo en cuenta su
antigüedad con hojas enteras
es algo realmente excepcional pero para
ella el verdadero interés está en la
eventual presencia de polen que rastrea
con el microscopio porque podría dar
algunas respuestas primero puede
informarnos acerca de eventuales
depósitos voluntarios de vegetales para
entender un poco los ritos funerarios
pero también podríamos saber si hubo
prácticas funerarias post mortem
es decir procesos de embalsamamiento
externo
con pasta vegetal o embalsamamiento
interno con evisceración
que usualmente se hacía con plantas que
ayudaban a preservar o reducir los
olores para transportar el cuerpo o para
exhibirlo
los resultados de estas investigaciones
Se esperan en 2024
entre tanto las primeras piezas de la
aguja de notre dame ya llegaron al sitio
de la obra las vigas se ensamblan al pie
de la Catedral antes de ser levantadas
cada pieza pesa cerca de cinco toneladas
y debe subirse a más de 60 metros de
altura una operación de mucha atención
es muy delicado por el peso de las
piezas que se deben montar y que se
deben ubicar entre los andamios y la
mampostería
la destreza del operador de la grúa será
lo más importante allá arriba luego
subirán los carpinteros para guiar la
pieza hasta el lugar correcto
y después podremos ocuparnos de los
detalles una vez que esté ubicada
la precisión será fundamental
no está mal en términos de nivel falta
poco
[Música]
ahí incluso podría subir así porque la
estaremos apoyando desde este lado y
después tú puedes volver a bajarla en el
techo de notre dame todo está listo para
recibir las piezas del taburete una vez
que estén instaladas los carpinteros
podrán empezar a ensamblar la aguja
pronto veremos levantarse a 100 metros
de altura un enorme andamio desde el
suelo de la Catedral es la altura de la
aguja y el andamio acompañará el montaje
de la aguja a partir de finales de este
año 2023 empezaremos a cubrir la aguja y
entonces el andamio irá bajando a medida
que se vaya completando la cobertura en
paralelo la famosa estructura conocida
como el bosque de notre dame se
reconstruirá poco a poco también será
una réplica idéntica tan parecida que
hasta se reproducirán los errores
cometidos en la época de su construcción
de hecho la catedral fue un experimento
constante y la estructura también los
primeros experimentos de la estructura
inicial del siglo XIII eran restaurados
de manera idéntica a veces incluso hemos
tenido que discutir con los carpinteros
para decirles sabemos que no está
perfecto se podría hacer mejor pero no
lo vamos a cambiar porque la catedral
resistió muy bien durante ocho siglos
antes del incendio Entonces no hay
ninguna razón para cambiar algo El Roble
del Siglo 21 servirá para construir una
estructura del siglo 13 estas complejas
operaciones durarán todo el año y podrán
ser contempladas por los parisinos y los
turistas desde los puentes y las calles
mientras esperan poder volver a entrar
en una de las catedrales más hermosas
del mundo en diciembre de 2024
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta a nottoidam este
tercer episodio de nuestra serie nos
mostró los avances para cumplir con el
objetivo de la reapertura en 2024
recuerde que puede Ingresar a nuestra
página web France 24.com para ver esta
emisión y las anteriores hasta la
próxima